Stavljava
jeste EUR
ja sam EUR stavljao
EUR?
dobro ok, sve jedno da li su EUR ili DOLAR
to 17 pa to je
a ti si stavio kurst DOLAR, fiksan kurst EUR
čini mi se da da
čekaj
onda to može da bude, čekaj ko je 690
je samo koliko tebe je, 47
izviješ te, prehidam, može da se promeni u poruđbenici, odnosi se unese
šta se unese?
u poruđbenici, kurs
ali ti u poruđbenici kada unosiš kurs
Ti u tom trenutku ne znaš koliko ćeš platiti, ali ti kad poručuješ obo ne platiš šta, nego plaćaš...
da, nešta možeš ovde, vrednost fakture
možeš unese vrednost fakture
tipa, staviš ovako, nešta možeš
ne, možeš najbolj, najlakši ovako, vrednost fakture
pa da se zabere koja je
valuta i da se stavi srednji kurs
dobro
reći moži
Može, može.
To.
Tarina uvek ide u dinarima,
transport,
transport može da ide u dinarima.
Novo,
to je to.
I sad,
sad sam odim,
i onda ćeš imati,
imat ćeš
vrednost dolara,
kurz dolara, koji množiš,
onda ovde bi možda mogo dole
Zvučaš koja je nabavna cena za tu poružbenicu, tipa ova šifra, 110,1,7,4, nabavna cena je 16,9 dobra, a ko je vrednost faktura 1,8,2,7,6,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7,7
Ne, to da už.
Ne, o sami su dvešče.
Si, ja ba se to na supros.
Hvala vam.
Bilo 6,9 puta 6,9 puta 600 komada, pa dobro računa ovo obrat.
Dobro računa, ne znam kako si ti to, ali to je to.
Pa ajde raditi kako si rekao sad, da ti bude lakše, mislim, preglednije.
Pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa
4 puta 5,7 puta 6,3,4,7,8
a jeba mater brate, to je isto
vidim, meni nije problem to da napravim, kao što ti sad rekao
pa nam mislim, tako je po knjižki, kako treba se računa kog se
važni biti tako onda
dobro, e sad, onda stvarna carina
dobro
ovde ne znam kako